je rappelle les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement notre séance est
retransmise en direction Public Sénat et
sur notre site internet
chacun sera attentif au respect des uns
et des autres et à celui du temps de
parole et je donne immédiatement la
parole au président Guillaume Gontard
pour le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire
merci
président madame la Première ministre le
prince Président nous a gratifié à leur
méridienne de sa bonne parole totalement
hors sol il a annoncé continué à avancer
à marche forcée totalement hors sol il a
osé comparer l'un des plus grands
mouvements populaires de notre histoire
à la sédition factieuse des
suprémacistes blancs envahissant le
Capitole
sol il a insulté les
mainstant sans avoir un mot pour
condamner les exactions de la police qui
s'ouvrent aux ordres tabasse nasse jette
des grenades en pleine tête roulent à
moto sur les gens intimides et arrête
n'importe qui n'importe quand sur le
regard à l'armée du Défenseur des droits
totalement hors sol et a plu à une
incohérence près il a quand même reconnu
que cette réforme était brutale et
surtout incomplète qu'elle ne
s'intéressait ni à la réalité du travail
ni à la pénibilité ni aux fins de
carrière ni ou reconversion alors madame
la première
avec gravité avec inquiétude nous vous
le demandons solennellement revenez à la
réalité et retirer cette réforme avant
d'avoir un drame sur la conscience
quand vous répond de la parole l'état
madame la Première ministre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs
les
après des semaines où l'on a pu voir
beaucoup de postures il est temps de
rappeler quelques vérités oui cette
réforme est nécessaire pour assurer
l'avenir de nos retraites
sans elle les déficites ce serait
accumulés et nous aurions été contraints
à des hausses d'impôts ou des baisses de
pension au détriment des plus modestes
et des classes moyennes
oui cette réforme a fait l'objet de
concertation intense avec le ministre du
Travail Olivier du soft depuis l'automne
dernier nous avons rencontré les
organisations syndicales et patronales
et les groupes parlementaires à de
nombreuses reprises et le projet a
considérablement évolué grâce à ses
concertations et oui cette réforme est
le fruit d'un débat parlementaire long
et dense avec plus de 175 heures en
séance et un accord trouvé en commission
mixte paritaire et oui le compromis
fonctionne nous avons travaillé ensemble
bâti un projet qui reprend des
propositions que la majorité
sénatoriale portée parfois depuis
longtemps mais aussi des idées qui
n'étaient pas les vôtres
issus de l'assemblée et ce projet vous
l'avez adopté par deux fois à une large
majorité je veux saluer les membres de
la majorité sénatoriale et ceux qui
l'action du Président de la République
pour leur engagement au service de notre
modèle social enfin oui nous avons
respecté l'esprit et la lettre de la
Constitution et nous sommes arrivés au
terme du cheminement parlementaire de
cette réforme et en revanche
nos bras
l'intérêt d'agog
ique
et je veux rendre hommage à nos
policiers et nos gendarmes pour leur
engagement au service de l'ordre
républicain
monsieur le monsieur le président
Gontard comme l'a dit le président de la
République tout à l'heure nous entendons
les doutes et les colères qui
s'expriment dans les mouvements sociaux
et qui dépasse largement la question des
retraites je pense à cette demande de
justice et nous devons veiller à ce que
les travailleurs bénéficient davantage
des profits exceptionnels de certaines
entreprises je pense aux attentes de nos
concitoyens dans leur rapport au travail
à notre capacité à prévenir l'usure
professionnelle et à offrir des
perspectives de carrière à chacun nous
devons continuer sur le chemin de la
réindustrialisation et du pleine emploi
car il permettront d'assurer notre
souveraineté et l'avenir de notre modèle
social nous devons veiller à l'ordre
républicain avec des moyens
supplémentaires pour nos forces de
l'ordre et notre justice nous devons
permettre à nos compatriotes de vivre
mieux en prenant des décisions aux
effets sensibles rapides en travaillant
avec nos collectivités sur la santé sur
l'éducation sur la transition écologique
autour de ce cap le président de la
République m'a chargé d'engager un
travail avec tous les parlementaires qui
veulent agir pour notre pays nous en
sommes capables nous l'avons montré
encore récemment en bâtissant des
majorités de projets autour de la loi
sur les énergies renouvelables ou encore
hier à l'Assemblée nationale sur le
nucléaire mais monsieur le Président
comptard dans des périodes d'inquiétude
l'immobilisme n'est jamais la solution
je vous remercie
pour nous répondre la parole est pas
pour vous répondre réplique madame la
Première ministre sortez de votre
côté je vous croyais
évident même les ressorts autoritaires
de nos constitutions d'un autre temps
sont brisés vous ne pouvez pas gouverner
en technocrate de palais contre le
peuple nous sommes entrés cette semaine
dans un de ces moments récurrent de
notre histoire ou le fleuve de la colère
populaire est sorti de son lit seul le
pouvoir exécutif peut enterrir la source
et rétablir le calme retirez votre
réforme européenne et remettez tout à
plat le travail la retraite
raite tout à l'heure et tant que vous y
êtes lancez aussi la refonte de nos
intestus des institutions anachroniques
pour que les mots du Président j'ai le
sens de la démocratie ne soit pas un
énième mensonge une énième provocation
vous n'avez de toute façon plus de
majorité pour faire autre chose
la parole est à notre collègue Colette
Melo pour le groupe Les Indépendants
républicains
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues dans un contexte de forte
inflation nos entrepreneurs sont
préoccupés ils ont suivi avec beaucoup
d'attention les incidents des secteurs
bancaires étrangers ainsi que les
réponses apportées par les régulateurs
indispensable pour contenir l'envolée
des prix qui ronge le pouvoir d'achat de
nos concitoyens la hausse des taux
directeurs entraînent dans le même temps
un renchérissement du crédit alors que
l'investissement est toujours nécessaire
à une économie de croissance il est
encore davantage lorsque l'on ambitionne
de réindustrialiser le pays
le président de la République a rappelé
à plusieurs reprises combien il était
essentiel à notre souveraineté que nous
puissions de nouveau produire en France
nous partageons ce constat et nous avons
soutenu le gouvernement dans la prise de
mesure destinée à favoriser le retour de
l'industrie sur notre sol notamment par
la baisse des impôts de production
aujourd'hui le chef de l'État vient
d'annoncer la mise en place prochaine
d'une contribution des entreprises en
faveur des salariés monsieur le ministre
dans un contexte où nos entreprises ont
autant besoin d'être rassurés que nos
concitoyens pourriez-vous nous donner
des éclaircissements quant à ce nouveau
dispositif s'agit-il d'une nouvelle taxe
comment la compétitivité la capacité
d'investissement de nos entreprises
seront-elles préservées
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique vous avez la parole monsieur
le ministre merci monsieur le Président
Madame et messieurs les sénateurs
nous partageons totalement votre
objectif de trouver le bon équilibre
entre la compétitivité des entreprises
notamment de notre industrie et la
nécessité de mieux partager la valeur
pour les salariés pour que tous ceux qui
travaillent on est tout simplement pour
leur engagement c'est ce que nous avons
fait depuis 6 ans nous avons simplifié
l'intéressement simplifier les accords
de participation nous avons supprimé la
taxe à 20% qui pesait sur les accords
d'intéressement de participation nous
avons mis en place avec le président de
la République la prime défiscalisée
jusqu'à 6000 euros pour redistribuer de
la valeur pour les salariés nous avons
également demandé à toutes les
entreprises qui bénéficient de rente je
pense aux entreprises énergéticiennes de
redistribuer cette rente à travers la
contribution sur la rente d'un frame
marginale qui rapporte plusieurs
milliards d'euros et qui financent le
bouclier énergétique que nous avons mis
en place avec la première milice la
proposition du Président de la
République c'est la troisième étape de
cette meilleure répartition de la valeur
entre le salarié et l'entreprise nous
voulons que les entreprises qui font du
rachat d'action donc qui ont donc les
moyens de le faire contribuent davantage
à la meilleure rémunération des salariés
nous voulons donc les obliger à
distribuer plus intéressant plus de
participation plus de primes
défiscalisées lorsqu'elles font du
rachat d'action nous voulons que ce soit
substantiel nous pourrions envisager par
exemple un doublement des sommes versées
au titre de la participation de
l'intéressement ou des primes des
fiscalisées pour toutes les grandes
entreprises qui font du rachat d'action
de quelles entreprises parlons-nous les
grandes entreprises celles qui ont plus
de 5000 salariés et celles qui du rachat
d'action quelle est la méthode que nous
privilégions avec la Premier ministre
c'est celle d'une proposition qui est
faite aux partenaires sociaux pour qu'il
négocie sur cette meilleure
participation ce meilleur intéressement
cette distribution plus large d'action
pour les grandes entreprises qui ont
recours à ces actions gratuites voilà la
proposition que nous faisons le rachat
d'action pardon voilà la proposition que
nous faisons avec la Premier ministre et
avec le président de la République pour
un meilleur partage de la valeur madame
mélo
merci monsieur le ministre de nous avoir
rappelé déjà été prises et les nouvelles
mesures dont on nous attendons bien sûr
beaucoup de retombées avec de nouvelles
repas une nouvelle répartition avec une
contribution des grandes entreprises
afin que des intéressements et une
participation puisse améliorer les
conditions de vie de nos concitoyens
merci merci la parole est à notre
collègue Serge bavary pour le groupe les
républicain
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le 19 janvier
dernier j'ai interrogé le ministre de
l'économie et des finances sur les
difficultés de fonctionnement du guichet
unique des entreprises mis en place le
premier janvier sa réponse est alors
voulue rassurante le dispositif serait
corrigé dans les toutes prochaines
semaines avec une échéance fixée au
début du mois de mars pas plus tard
depuis cette échéance est sans cesse
repoussée sur votre suggestion madame la
ministre notre délégation aux
entreprises s'est déplacée alienpi le 8
février dernier et nous avons pu
constater l'ampleur et la complexité de
la tâche en dépit de solution temporaire
tels que la réouverture d'un progrès ce
service de simplification continue de
dysfonctionner jusqu'à compromettre en
particulier l'avenir de la filière
artisanale
première difficulté le registre national
des entreprises n'est pas fiable et ne
comporte aucune mention d'appartenance
au secteur des métiers et la qualité
artisanale les chambres de métiers sont
dans l'incapacité de fournir des
extraits d'inscription
issue du Registre national la synthèse
obtenue après validation n'étant pas
reconnue par les partenaires banque et
assureurs
deuxième difficulté la complexité du
système de catégorisation les
entreprises artisanales ne sont tout
bonnement plus identifiées l'alerte est
donnée les chambres des métiers ne
peuvent plus exercer leur mission de
contrôle elles sont contraintes de
maintenir leur logiciel métier en
doublon du guichet unique ce qui
représente un coup important le réseau
des CMA a formulé les propositions
madame la ministre quelle suite allez
vous y donner quelles mesures allez vous
prendre pour fiabiliser le registre issu
du guichet unique et permettre une
meilleure identification de l'activité
et de la qualification artisanale je
vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole est à la ministre délégué chargé
des prix des moyens d'entrepris du
commerce et de l'artisanat
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Babarit vous le savez depuis
le 1er janvier nous travaillons
constamment avant le guichet unique
totalement opérationnel pour les
formalités d'entreprise et effectivement
on en a parlé ensemble et je vous
remercie d'ailleurs
au sujet de la délégation des
entreprises d'avoir pris le temps
d'aller voir aussi les équipes de l'INPI
pour mesurer leur engagement le
déploiement il se poursuit à date nous
dénombrons plus de 470 000 formalités
création et modifications il y a pas
aujourd'hui et vous le savez monsieur le
Président Babari de problèmes sur les
créations on a en revanche très
clairement encore des difficultés sur
les formalités de modifications et de
cessation d'activité hier on a franchi
une nouvelle étape avec la bascule des
formalités de cessation sur le guichet
unique ce qui nous rapproche et garantit
l'objectif de parvenir à un outil unique
d'ici à la fin juin pour autant il
existe des marges d'amélioration vous
les avez mentionnées monsieur le
président gabarit notamment sur le
traitement des déclarations des
entreprises artisanales je pense au
problème des multi-validations les cas
dans lequel un artisan doit obtenir la
validation de ces données par la CMA
mais aussi par le greffier du tribunal
de commerce mes services ce sont ces
sujets les travaux accélèrent pour
améliorer et faciliter le partage
d'information la qualité est la
précision du registre national des
entreprises est aussi un enjeu ce
registre que vous connaissez a été conçu
pour regrouper les données toutes les
entreprises il est légitime que les
entreprises du secteur des métiers et de
l'artisanat soient clairement identifiés
en tant que tel au sein du registre il y
a des insuffisances encore à date au
sein du registre là aussi nous
accélérons et nous travaillons pour les
corriger le plus rapidement possible
enfin vous l'avez mentionné la
catégorisation la catégorisation
monsieur le Président barbarie je veux
quand même dire quel a été bâtie et
définie avec tous les partenaires du
projet dont CMA France soyons clairs
c'est un des enjeux les plus importants
les plus complexes pour le
fonctionnement du guichet unique
l'engagement du ministère de l'économie
est total vous l'avez dit le 8 février
vous y êtes allé monsieur le Président
babary comme tous les projets
informatiques d'ampleur il est complexe
on sera au rendez-vous fin juin je vous
remercie
monsieur bavary vous avez quelques
secondes
madame la ministre la difficulté
principale c'est que ça devait être
opérationnel au 1er janvier et que
depuis trois mois les entreprises ont de
grandes difficultés non plus à
s'inscrire comme vous l'avez dit mais à
faire quelques modifications que ce soit
ou pour les artisans à pouvoir être pris
en considération pour leur relation avec
les banques les assureurs et autres
intervenants donc il faut faire au plus
vite et je l'avais indiqué à monsieur le
ministre
c'est une difficulté de simplifier mais
la numérisation ne règle pas tout merci
la parole est au président Jean-François
Longeot pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste j'avais la parole monsieur le
président
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'économie il y a deux jours le GIEC
publiait la synthèse de son sixième
rapport un document très attendu et qui
résonne comme un coup de ce Mons
l'humanité est au pied du mur face au
réchauffement climatique c'est agir ou
périr notre gouvernement à l'Union
européenne en ont bien conscience ce
dont témoignent les efforts
d'accélération de la transition
environnementale bonjour or aujourd'hui
même sort une étude relative à l'impact
sur l'emploi que risque d'avoir cette
transition dans notre pays un travail
qui émane du Centre d'études prospective
et d'information internationales
un service qui dépend de Matignon et
dans la qualité des travaux n'est plus à
démontrer selon cette étude la
transition écologique pourrait avoir le
même effet que la désindustrialisation
ayant lieu depuis 1997 alors où Bercy
achève la co-construction de son projet
de loi pour un industrie verte le
problème est crucial les auteurs de
l'étude soulignent que selon la
Commission européenne entre 35 et 40%
des emplois pourraient être touchés par
la transition écologique la question clé
est de savoir s'il pourra y avoir une
réallocation de main de fluide entre les
secteurs gagnants c'est-à-dire les
secteurs décarbonés et les secteurs
polluants en état actuel des choses rien
n'est moins sûr car jusqu'ici les plans
sociaux ne se sont jamais faits s'encas
humaine au moins pour les travailleurs
les moins qualifiés qui ont toujours
peiné à retrouver un emploi et encore
plus à ne pas subir une importante
baisse de salaire
monsieur le ministre ma question est
donc simple comment anticipez-vous le
problème de la mutation nécessaire de
l'emploi dans le cadre de la transition
vers une industrie verte je vous
remercie pour vos réponses la parole est
au ministre de l'économie des finances
et de la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique chez le ministre et monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs hélas trois fois hélas il y a
pas eu besoin d'avoir une transition
climatique pour qu'il y ait des
délocalisations industrielles de masse
depuis trois décennies dans notre pays
la faute française elle est là
2 millions d'emplois industriels
détruits depuis les années 80 des
usines qui ferment absolument partout
une richesse nationale et une part de la
production industrielle dans la richesse
nationale qui passe de 20% à juste un
peu plus de 10%. ça c'est trois
décennies de politique
anti-industriels qui entraîné cette
délocalisation avec le président de la
République depuis 2017 nous avons pris
les mesures nécessaires pour obtenir des
résultats la première décision que nous
ayons prise c'est de baisser l'impôt sur
les sociétés c'est de baisser les impôts
de production et de mettre en place un
prélèvement forfait ironique parce que
il n'y a pas d'industrie son capital
baisser la fiscalité sur le capital
c'est augmenter l'industrialisation du
pays voilà des vérités que personne ne
voulait voir en face résultat nous
ouvrons aujourd'hui plus d'usine que
nous enfermons et nous recréons pour la
première fois du 3 décennies 88 000
emplois industriels depuis deux ans en
France et je vais vous dire ma
conviction la transition climatique est
une chance pour notre industrie nous
allons avec le ministre de l'Industrie
proposé une loi sur l'industrie verte
qui va favoriser la commande publique
pour les produits industriels Verts
français et européen nous allons mettre
en place des crédits d'impôts et des
mesures fiscales plus fortes pour tous
ceux qui travaillent dans l'hydrogène
verte dans les batteries électriques
dans les panneaux solaires dans les
véhicules électriques pour favoriser la
création d'emplois verts et industriels
dans notre pays nous allons faire en
sorte d'accélérer l'ouverture des usines
et l'extension des usines vertes
existantes pour accélérer les
relocalisations industrielles et
accélérer les créations d'emplois nous
devons conjuguer croissance et climat
c'est ce qui a toujours été la ligne de
force du gouvernement de la Premier
ministre et du président de la
République les résultats sont là nous
allons accélérer
que le président Longeot
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Michel
Gréau pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologique il y
avait la parole le Président Monsieur le
Ministre un peuple
refroidi contre cette réforme dont il ne
veut pas le recul à 64 ans de l'âge de
départ à la retraite face au mouvement
social massif qui porte l'exigence de
retrait face à une Assemblée nationale
qui n'a voté la réforme ni en première
lecture ni en seconde lecture vous vous
enfermez avec le président de la
République dans un repli autoritaire
lourdes danger pour la démocratie vous
avez affirmé vouloir aller au bout du
cheminement démocratique quelle
provocation c'est bien un chemin de
croix auquel nous assistons rythmé par
les articles désormais connus de tous 47
à 44 3 49.3 monsieur le ministre comment
parler de cheminement démocratique alors
que depuis jeudi le droit de manifester
est mis en cause avec mon groupe je
demande que soit mis à l'étude le
comportement des forces de sécurité
depuis jeudi soir il ne s'agit pas de
cautionner des dégradations mais nous
assistons à des violences policières et
réquisitions inacceptable
l'ont habilité mais l'ordre ce n'est pas
le matraquage et gazage à tout va c'est
savoir entendre la foule l'opinion le
peuple qui dit non la colère élan elle
montre la morgue et le mépris du chef de
l'État ne passeront pas cette fois-ci à
la répression policière ne peut être la
voie pour résoudre 16 crises politiques
sociales très profondes le chef de
l'État droit dans ses bacs ne veut ni
dissolution ni référendum ni remaniement
qu'il retire alors ce projet si injuste
si par malheur monsieur Macron ne veut
assumer cet échec s'il s'y refuse nous
le contrats par la demande de référendum
d'initiative partagée que nous avons
lancé monsieur Macron lors de son
interview insipidé inutile affirme
choisir l'intérêt général en réalité
entre le peuple et l'intérêt des riches
il a choisi l'intérêt des riches demain
sera une formidable journée cette
journée ou un peuple unie une foule
immense légitime se lèvera pour défendre
sa condition pour défendre ses droits
madame la Première ministre est encore
temps retirer votre projet merci
monsieur la parole est au pénis du
travail je suis Olivier du soft vous
avez la parole
merci à Monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs madame
sénatrice oui le projet de loi pourtant
réforme des retraites est allé au bout
de son cheminement démocratique et il va
continuer à y aller ce projet de loi
fait suite à quatre mois de concertation
il a fait l'objet de plus de 165 heures
de débat l'Assemblée nationale et au
Sénat et votre assemblée le Sénat la
voté à deux reprises une première fois
en première lecture après l'examen de
chacun des articles et une seconde fois
après que la commission mixte paritaire
est trouvée une conclusion partagée
c'est la démonstration que je vais aller
au bout et s'il a semblée nationale n'a
pu voter en première lecture c'est
uniquement par l'obstruction
systématique et organisée par les
groupes de gauche qui ont privé
l'Assemblée nationale de sa capacité à
délibérer ce projet de loi il est
nécessaire madame la sénatrice
nécessaire pour faire face à déficit
structurels nécessaires pour améliorer
le système de retraite et sa mise en
oeuvre à la fin de l'année lorsque le
Conseil constitutionnel ce sera prononcé
permettra de revaloriser l'équipe
pensions de mieux prendre en compte la
pénibilité mais aussi de mieux
accompagner celle de ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler bientôt madame
sénatrice vous avez parlé à deux
reprises de responsabilité la
responsabilité c'est de prendre cette de
faire cette réforme de prendre la
décision d'aller au bout de cette
réforme pour sauver le système et faire
en sorte que les générations qui
viennent puissent accéder à un système
de retraite qui les protège et qui
justement protégera les plus fragiles et
puis la responsabilité madame la
sénatrice c'est que lorsque la
mobilisation sociale est organisée
lorsqu'elle se passe bien il faut la
saluer mais lorsqu'il y a des violences
il faut les condamner et quand on
condamne les violences faites de la
médecinatrice on soutient les forces de
police on soutient les forces de police
placées sur l'autorité du ministre de
l'Intérieur et je profite de votre
question pour saluer leur travail je
salue l'ensemble des forces de police et
de gendarmerie qui par leur intervention
garantissent la sécurité le maintien de
l'ordre c'est aussi l'expression de la
démocratie et la liberté
la parole de notre collègue Julien
barjoton pour le groupe du Rassemblement
des démocrates progressifs et
indépendants vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre de la transition énergétique
madame la ministre une surconsommation
et un surdéveloppement vampirique une
exploitation non durable des ressources
en eau la pollution et le réchauffement
climatique incontrôlée sont en train
d'épuiser goutte après-goutte cette
source de vie pour l'humanité ainsi
s'exprime Antonio gouttieres dans le
rapport qui va ouvrir cette session
inédite de l'ONU consacrée à l'eau qui
débute aujourd'hui les inondations au
Pakistan en 2022 nous ont montré les
conséquences sur le cycle de l'eau du
réchauffement de notre planète 33
millions de personnes concernées 1700
morts 1,8 millions d'hectares de terres
agricoles dévastées le sixième rapport
de synthèse du GIEC montrent que ces
épisodes seront de plus en plus intenses
et de plus en plus récurrents sous nos
latitudes dans notre pays
historiquement sec que nous venons de
traverser nous montre qu'il est plus que
jamais nécessaire de préserver cette
ressource qui est un des enjeux
principaux de notre siècle ces
impératifs nous pressent donc de
modifier notre rapport à l'eau nos modes
de gestion afin d'en assurer sa qualité
sa quantité et son caractère
renouvelable cette incertitude implique
également de replacer l'eau au cœur de
tous nos débats sur les changements
climatiques le gouvernement a annoncé
dévoilé prochainement 50 mesures
relatives à la gestion relative à la
gestion de l'eau alors dans le cadre de
cette journée de l'eau pour l'ONU madame
la ministre pouvez-vous nous en dire
davantage sur le contenu de ces
propositions afin de renforcer
d'améliorer la gestion de l'eau dans
notre pays pour en rassurer la qualité
et la quantité pour nos concitoyens
merci beaucoup pour vous répondre la
parole madame panier runacheminis de la
transition énergétique vous avez la
parole madame la ministre
merci Président Mesdames et Messieurs
les Sénateurs monsieur le
c'est une excuser mon collègue
Christophe bichu ministre la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires qui comme vous le savez
fortement investi sur ce sujet et qui
rencontrera dans les prochains jours
Antonio Guterres précisément pour porter
un agenda sur l'eau qui soit
particulièrement ambitieux tant en plan
international Coplan national vous avez
raison également de mentionner le
rapport du GIEC qui confirme l'extrême
urgence à agir pour atteindre les
objectifs de l'accord de Paris en
matière climatique ce rapport il invite
à l'action et cette action nous l'avons
prise en main sous l'égide de la du
président de la République et de la
première ministre je rappelle que le
premier quinquennat du président de la
République a permis de doubler le rythme
de baisse de nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et nous continuons à agir
je ne reviendrai pas sur le vote très
large sur ces bancs de la loi énergie
renouvelable et du projet de loi une
nucléaire qui sont autant d'éléments
pour agir pour notre planète et lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique
s'agissant de la ressource en eau cette
ressource est un enjeu majeur en France
nous devons collectivement état comme
collectivité locale mieux anticiper la
diminution de la ressource en eau mieux
préparer les sécheresses à venir c'est
tout l'objet du plan o que la première
ministre et Christophe BECHU
présenteront très prochainement et qui
est une brique importante de l'ensemble
de la planification écologique voulue
par le président de la République nous
devons engager une réelle transition sur
trois axes la sobriété de nos usages ça
sera écho à la sobriété énergétique la
garantie de l'accès inopotame de qualité
et la restauration du grand cycle de
l'eau ce travail s'inscrit dans la
continuité des assises de l'eau et du
varen agricole il s'agit à l'échelle des
territoires de concilier d'un côté une
moindre disponibilité de la ressource et
de l'autre des besoins accrus ce sujet
est attendu des Français
et je peux vous le dire le gouvernement
sera au rendez-vous je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame la Présidente
Laurence Rossignol pour le groupe
socialiste
républicain merci monsieur le Président
que nous a dit le président de la
République tout à l'heure d'abord il
nous a dit que la majorité du pays
celles qui s'opposent à sa réforme
seraient dans le déni de la réalité et
dans l'ignorance et que lui seul nous
conduirait vers la lumière c'est une
insulte une insulte à l'intelligence des
Français il nous a dit que les
manifestants seraient noyauté par des
factures il est allé jusqu'à les
comparer au suprématisme de Brasilia ou
du Capitole c'est encore une insulte il
nous a dit que les syndicats auraient
refusé de négocier ça c'est un mensonge
a déjà répondu Laurent Berger il nous a
dit que nous n'aurions eu comme contre
proposition que l'augmentation des
déficits alors que aucun de nos
amendements n'a été retenu ni même
examiné y compris se tenant aux
cotisations patronales
c'est donc encore un mensonge il nous a
dit que les entreprises ne financaient
pas les retraites alors là j'ai cherché
et je n'ai vu qu'une seule explication
il a été trahi par son inconscient et en
réalité c'est son rêve mais c'est aussi
un mensonge encore
il nous a dit que les Français ne
voudraient plus travailler et qu'il
remettraient les bénéficiaires du RSA au
travail c'est une insulte à la crise
démocratique qu'il a approfondie à la
crise politique qu'il a ouverte il a
répondu par quoi la perspective de
nouveau débauchages sans doute les
députés qui n'ont pas voté la motion de
censure ça c'est une indécence et nous a
dit vouloir taxer les entreprises qui
rachètent leurs actions sauvez
l'éducation la santé l'industrie sans
jamais préciser ni ou ni corni comment
en revanche il n'a pas manqué de nous
dire que la réforme des retraites serait
appliquée sans délai alors madame la
Première ministre de matinal en 20h en
13h vous le présent de la République vos
ministres vous ne faites qu'à scéner les
mêmes arguments d'autorité la seule
autocritique que vous vous concédez
c'est celle d'une défaillance
pédagogique vous voulez apaiser le pays
je ne crois sincèrement mais il n'y a
qu'une solution rendez aux Français des
deux ans de vie que vous leur voulez
la parole
est au ministre des légumes en charge du
renouveau démocratique porte-parole du
gouvernement monsieur Véran
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs Madame la
Ministre
Laurent Rossignol je vous appelle pardon
je vous appelez madame la ministre parce
que en 2014 vous étiez ministre délégué
auprès de Marisol Touraine
j'ai été député socialiste
et vous et moi nous avons eu le courage
de soutenir en 2014 une réforme des
retraites portées par le gouvernement
socialiste auquel vous apparteniez et
que j'ai donc soutenu comme
parlementaire socialiste et qui a
pardonné moi du peu allongé la durée de
cotisation pour tous les Français qui
travaillent et vous l'avez fait dans un
souci de justice et vous l'avez fait
avec un objectif équilibré un système de
retraite qui ne l'était plus dans la
durée alors je vous dis ça madame la
sénatrice je pourrais aussi vous
rappeler qu'à l'époque lorsque vous
faisiez partie du gouvernement il y a eu
l'adoption d'un texte important
courageux nécessaire pour l'économie
notre pays adopté par un 49.3 vous étiez
au gouvernement vous ne l'avez pas
quitté j'étais alors député du groupe
socialiste je ne l'ai pas quitté comme
quoi madame
comme quoi je l'ai dit socialiste comme
quoi ça veut dire que vous avez sans
doute la mémoire sélective moi pas
Madame c'est la triche il se trouve
aussi qu'en écoutant votre question j'ai
l'impression que vous avez l'oreille
sélective moi pas ou plutôt l'oreille
déformante jamais le président de la
République n'a comparé les
manifestations avec des factions à aucun
moment il a fait le distinguo entre les
manifestations démocratiques dont il a
salué la qualité de l'organisation et la
sécurisation par les organisations
syndicales il la distingué de groupes
oui madame la sédatrice de violents qui
viennent de l'ultra gauche et qui
sergent qui cherche à saquer nos villes
mais surtout même la sénatrice parce que
nous venons du même bord quand on vous
dit qu'on va augmenter les petits
salaires en dessous du SMIC vous devez
dire oui quand on dit qu'on va améliorer
les fins de carrière pour les salariés
vous devez dire oui quand on vous dit
qu'on va lever une contribution
exceptionnelle pour les grands groupes
quand ils rachète des actions vous
devriez dire oui et quand on propose de
conclure des bénéficiaires du RSA loin
de l'emploi en formation ou à l'emploi
vous devriez applaudir avec nous et
madame la sénatrice c'est ça avoir de la
mémoire et du courage et de la
conviction dans la continuité
madame Rossignol non
la parole est à notre collègue Guylaine
Portel pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire
sécheresse hivernale historique
inflation difficulté de transmission des
exploitations élevage pastoraux en péril
prédation la vulnérabilité du monde
agricole est perceptible dans des
discussions à bâton rompu que nous
pouvons avoir avec les professionnels du
secteur
les réponses apportées par les autorités
sont parfois insatisfaisantes et
suscitent l'agacement l'anxiété ou la
résignation
s'ajoutent à cela l'équation complexe
sur les contours du futur dispositif
d'affichage environnemental sur les
produits alimentaires
initiés par la loi relative à la lutte
contre le gaspillage et à l'économie
circulaire remodelé par la loi climat et
résilience
ce projet d'envergure fait l'objet d'un
travail de concertation piloté par
l'ADEME et le ministère de la transition
écologique qui ont collecté des
contributions jusqu'au 10 mars dernier
notamment sur les modalités d'affichage
l'analyse du cycle de vie et la méthode
d'évaluation privilégiée pour classer
les produits ou les services en fonction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
des atteintes à la biodiversité et de la
consommation d'eau et d'autres
ressources naturelles
en découle l'attribution d'une note qui
sera affichée sur les produits ou
services à rayonnage ou sur Internet
bien que cela réponde à une inspiration
légitime des consommateurs bon nombre de
producteurs craignent que cela soit
inadapté à des produits locaux et
artisanaux à l'image de ce qui avait été
observé avec le nutriscor pardon la
demande des exploitants agricoles est
simple n'engendrez pas de nouvelles
sources de découragement
ainsi Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous
nous assurer que le nouvel outil
d'affichage environnemental ne
présentera pas les mêmes défaillances
que le nutriscor à l'égard de produits
du terroir je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Madame Dominique Faure ministre délégué
en charge des collectivités
territoriales et de la ruralité
monsieur le Président merci mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Pantel les ministres
Christophe Béchu et Bérengère Couillard
étant en ce jour à la Conférence des
Nations Unies sur l'eau à New York il
vous prie de bien vouloir les excuser
pour leur absence et me charge de
répondre à votre question la transition
écologique comme vous le savez est au
coeur de l'action gouvernementale et la
planification écologique est une
priorité de notre première ministre
l'information du consommateur et vous
l'avez souligné sur les caractéristiques
environnementales des produits qu'ils
achètent et fondamental pour faire
évoluer nos modes de consommation nous
voulons et nous devons permettre aux
consommateurs de devenir des consonnes
acteurs c'est la raison pour laquelle la
loi climat est résilience a prévu la
mise en place d'un affichage
environnemental des produits cette
affichage intégrera les enjeux d'impact
liés à la fabrication au transport des
produits en tenant compte des ressources
extraites de la consommation d'eau des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ou
encore des impacts sur la biodiversité
alors vous questionnez la méthode
plusieurs expérimentations ont été
conduites en 2021 pour les produits
alimentaires et en 2022 pour les
vêtements textils ma collègue Bérengère
Couillard a réuni dès le mois d'octobre
2022 les associations de consommateurs
les ONG et les porteurs de ces
expérimentations pour recueillir leurs
attentes et leurs idées pour construire
ensemble cette affichage environnemental
une priorité a été donnée aux produits
alimentaires et aux vêtements textiles
l'objectif est de proposer pour ces deux
se un affichage environnemental qui
pourra être déployé dès le début de
l'année 2024 par les entreprises
volontaires avant de devenir obligatoire
comme le prévoit la loi concernant plus
spécifiquement le secteur alimentaire
pas de découragement pas de défaillance
ma collègue Bérengère Couillard réunira
les parties prenantes le 27 mars
prochain pour lancer une véritable
concertation sur la première version du
projet de méthode de calcul de
l'affichage environnemental des produits
alimentaires je vous remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Jean-Baptiste blanc pour le groupe les
républicains
le seul président
ma question s'adressait à Monsieur le
Ministre Christophe Béchu le Sénat s'est
livré depuis près d'un an un travail
patient et minutieux de travail et
d'écoute et d'expertise du zan c'était
édifice au nombre vices cachées au terme
d'une maturation collective et
transpartisane ça rime nous avons avec
Valérie léthard et la commission
spéciale la semaine dernière fait
adopter à une large majorité une
proposition de loi d'initiatives
sénatoriale qui consolide les fondations
et confort tout l'ouvrage pour qu'il
puisse traverser le temps il faut le
répéter face au mauvais procès qui sont
faits à notre texte le Sénat n'a pas
bouleversé l'architecture du zan les
cibles les trajectoires sont intactes
des ajustements de la souplesse des
outils nouveaux étaient nécessaires pour
répondre aux inquiétudes voire à la
colère de certains élus locaux nous les
avons écoutés et prise au sérieux
longtemps muet sur le sujet le
gouvernement dit aujourd'hui être prêt à
adapter la loi il a longtemps
sous-estimé sous-estime encore le
potentiel hautement inflammable du zan
son approche comptable est
recentralisatrice et l'absence
d'accompagnement des collectivités face
à ces nouvelles obligations inquiète les
élus de tous les département et ici sur
tous les bancs nos auditions nous ont
convaincu qu'il était impératifs
d'apporter des réponses législatives à
des questions aussi variées que le
calendrier les grands projets la prise
en compte des efforts passés la garantie
rurale les communitorale les bâtiments
agricoles il fallait éteindre l'incendie
madame la ministre le texte nous avons
rédigé et largement adopté aujourd'hui
prêt à être examiné par l'Assemblée
nationale ma question est simple
tiendrez-vous votre promesse de
poursuivre la discussion sur la base du
texte adopté par le Sénat quand le texte
sera-t-il inscrit à l'Assemblée
nationale
pour vous répondre la parole état la
ministre déléguée chargée des
collectivités territoriales et la
ruralité merci
[Musique]
à toi monsieur le sénateur blanc
monsieur le rapporteur alors vous le
savez quelques mots avant de vous dire
oui mais quelques mots quand même vous
le savez chaque année 20000 hectares
d'espace naturel agricoles et forestiers
sont consommés en moyenne en France les
conséquences de ce phénomène sont
écologique vous le savez mais sont aussi
socio-économique notamment la diminution
du potentiel de production agricole
alors comme vous l'avez rappelé la
France est fixée cet objectif
d'atteindre à horizon de 2050 le 0
artificialisation net et un objectif
intermédiaire de réduction de moitié et
fixé à 2030 pour la consommation
d'espace naturel agricole forestier dans
les 10 prochaines années alors en
novembre dernier l'onde lors de son
discours de clôture du Congrès des
Maires madame la Première ministre a
rappelé que le gouvernement était prêt
un certain nombre d'évolution dont la
prise en compte des grands projets
d'envergure national et puis cette
garantie rurale à laquelle nous sommes
tous attachés les propositions du
gouvernement ont été défendues par
Christophe Béchu lors l'examen de la PPL
sénatorial sur le zan la semaine
dernière vous le savez monsieur le
rapporteur et non pas été retenus par le
Sénat qui a préféré ce que nous pensons
être une trajectoire moins économe en
termes d'artificialisation le
gouvernement considère aujourd'hui que
le texte du Sénat ne permet pas de
respecter la trajectoire ambitieuse de
réduction d'artificialisation que nous
portons et qui est fixé par la loi
climat et résilience alors cependant
monsieur le sénateur monsieur le
rapporteur cette proposition de loi
encore vocation à évoluer dans le cadre
de la navette parlementaire si
l'objet a
un compte acceptable pour l'ensemble des
acteurs que ce soit les députés les
sénateurs les associations d'élus locaux
ou les associations de défense de
l'environnement sur ce sujet aussi
important pour les Français comme pour
les élus locaux le gouvernement reste
très attaché à trouver un compromis
acceptable pour tous nous allons trouver
ensemble ce compromis monsieur le
rapporteur
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez la
parole
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
ne peut pas vous laisser dire que nous
nous sortons de la trajectoire nous
sommes dans la trajectoire je le dis le
redis madame Letard au Pin du chef voilà
au contraire nous pensons que seuls les
élus locaux pour remporter la transition
écologique et Lausanne faut juste leur
donner du temps des moyens des outils de
l'ingénierie proposant des choses
simples et encore une fois c'est très
hautement inflammable il faut écouter le
Sénat
la parole est à notre collègue Jean-Yves
Leconte pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre monsieur madame et Monsieur et
Madame et Monsieur des ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse
aux ministres de l'Intérieur la France
est dans la rue pour manifester son
désaccords profonds avec le passage en
force d'une réforme des retraites
qu'elle rejette en bloc d'une réforme
qui n'est pas soutable d'un point de vue
humain et social et dont le poids repose
exclusivement sur les efforts des
travailleurs des travailleurs c'est dans
ce contexte très tendu qui était prévu
l'examen dans l'hémicycle du Sénat le
projet de loi immigration et intégration
à compter de mardi prochain alors que
les droits des étrangers en France sont
déjà particulièrement dégradés qu'ils
sont soumis à des conditions de plus en
plus exigeantes et des procédures
toujours plus complexes qu'il les
maintiennent dans des situations de
précarité et d'insécurité juridique
administrative inacceptable une réforme
de leurs droits mérite d'être abordé
avec sérénité et sérieux
c'est pourquoi au vu du contexte le
groupe socialiste écologique et
républicain demandait le retrait de ce
projet de loi de l'ordre du jour de
notre assemblée monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous préciser les propos du
président de la République qui semblent
annoncer une série de textes découpant
votre projet loi façon puzzle quoi qu'il
arrive le gouverneur peut et doit
prendre rapidement les mesures qui
s'imposent contrairement à la
régularisation des travailleurs
étrangers il n'est pas besoin d'une loi
pour réviser au plus vite la liste des
métiers en tension dans le cadre d'une
concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux concertation ni pour donner des
instructions aux préfets en faveur de
l'administration de l'admission au
séjour des étrangers qui contribuent
chaque jour à l'effort national et
cotise pour nos retraites ainsi dans
l'attente de mesures législatives
permettant de sécuriser durablement leur
séjour et leur emploi il convient de ne
pas les maintenir dans une situation
inadmissible de précarité et d'agir
rapidement avec les outils existants
monsieur le ministre qu'attend donc le
gouvernement pour agir sur ses urgences
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de l'intérieur les outre-mer
monsieur Darmanin merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur de compte
vous avez bien entendu le président de
la République je vous remercie d'avoir
d'en faire écho de ces propositions ici
puisque nous avons en effet entendu le
Sénat monsieur le Président du Sénat du
même exprimé lors de sa rencontre avec
le président de la République je crois
savoir je suis un échange avec le
président buffet la commission des lois
et bien évidemment nous entendons votre
demande et c'est pour cela que dans
quelques instants va avec le ministre
des Parlement et monsieur le ministre du
Travail et moi-même proposé une méthode
de travail au Parlement à la semaine
nationale et au Sénat pour adopter des
mesures législatives qui sont
nécessaires pour évidemment améliorer
l'intégration mais également lutter
contre l'immigration irrégulière la
lutte contre les passeurs l'intégration
évidemment par la langue l'intégration
par le travail les délinquants étrangers
que nous devons plus facilement expulser
mais aussi les moyens donnés à notre
droit à nos préfectures je crois que
nous sommes tous d'accord pour dire que
c'est à la fois législatif et
extrêmement nécessaire cependant nous
avons entendu la nouvelle méthode de
travail voulu par le Président de la
République et par les chambres
parlementaires donc j'essayerai le soin
à la première ministre d'évoquer avec
les présidents de chambre sur le texte
qui me concerne et qui concerne les du
socle d'immigration mais sur tous les
autres textes la même méthode qu'elle
aura elle-même définie j'espère ainsi
avoir répondu à votre interrogation
monsieur le
con merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre je vous remercie de ces
précisions mais s'il y avait s'il y a
une volonté politique en particulier sur
l'intégration par le travail ce que vous
pouvez faire ce que vous pouviez faire
depuis 2017 depuis 2022 commencez à le
faire maintenant avant même de change on
n'a pas besoin de modifications
législatives pour un certain nombre de
choses la liste des métiers en tension
l'admission l'admission exceptionnel de
séjour allez-y montrez-nous que vous
avez sur ce sujet une volonté politique
et pas simplement des
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Antoine
Lefebvre pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de la Santé de la
prévention monsieur le ministre le 13
mars dernier les 10000 étudiants en 6e
année de médecine était appelé à passer
en centre d'examen des épreuves blanches
en prévision du concours d'entrée à
l'internat prévu en juin prochain
organisé par le Centre national de
gestion qui répondent la tutelle de
votre ministère les épreuves ont vite
tourné au fiasco bug à répétition
impossibilité de valider les réponses
ralentissement problème d'affichage
voire carrément déconnexion en cours
d'épreuve à tout juste trois mois des
véritables épreuves classantes
nationales qui sont décisives dans le
pour le choix de la spécificité la
spécialité et du lieu d'exercice ce coût
décès constitué pourtant une occasion
privilégiée pour les étudiants de se
situer par rapport au niveau national et
de tester en réel les conditions qui les
attendaient
en outre le concours répondait à de
nouvelles règles d'organisation suivant
une méthodologie inédite les étudiants
ne disposaient donc pas d'annales des
examens précédents ni de support pour
s'entraîner les réponses du CNG sont
tout aussi lunaires plutôt que d'assumer
la responsabilité d'un dysfonctionnement
sur le système informatique le centre
préfère minimiser le problème et
d'accuser une incompréhension sémantique
suggérant que les épreuves n'auraient
pas été un vrai concours blanc mais bien
un simple test pour vérifier la
performance du logiciel on croit rêvée
l'association des étudiants en médecine
de France demande à ce que de nouvelles
épreuves blanches puissent être
organisées dans les meilleurs délais sur
une plateforme fiable et opérationnelle
à trois mois des épreuves de classement
national qui détermineront toute la
carrière de nos futurs médecins quant à
les voir enfin mener une politique
ambitieuse d'investissement dans les
moyens mis à disposition nos étudiants
pouvez-vous garantir la totale fiabilité
du support numérique des épreuves d'ici
à juin merci
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
monsieur Braun
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Lefebvre heureusement
heureusement que cette panne a eu lieu
le 13 mars dernier parce que comme vous
l'avez dit c'était une épreuve blanche
mais une épreuve blanche sous les
étudiants n'était de toute façon pas
classés parce qu'il n'avait pas
évaluation de leur réponse c'était bien
une épreuve blanche pour tester cette
nouvelle plateforme informatique qui
répond aux évolutions du deuxième cycle
des études médicales et comme vous
l'avez très bien dit qui est nouvelle
donc cette épreuve a été interrompue et
la fonctionnait pour 85% des étudiants
mais effectivement un pourcentage sur
cette première épreuve n'a pas pu être
il n'arrivait pas à valider leur
résultat alors que s'est-il passé après
cette épreuve blanche et bien les
corrections étaient apportées le
lendemain 97% des bugs si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi était réglés et comme
nous n'étions pas à 100% et c'est
essentiel pour valider la plateforme de
test nous avons préféré reporter le
deuxième passage de cette épreuve
blanche je le rappelle sans classement
des étudiants il n'aurait pas les
résultats de toute façon de leur réponse
ce n'était qu'un test technique donc la
deuxième partie qui devait avoir lieu le
15 mars a été annulé bien entendu le CNG
a travaillé à corriger aujourd'hui
l'ensemble des difficultés il y aura une
nouvelle épreuve blanche qui se
déroulera fin avril début mai pour que
au mois de juin le résultat soit sans
discussion que cette épreuve puisse être
réalisée car comme vous l'avez très bien
dit elle est primordiale pour les
étudiants en médecine puisqu'elle
préjugent de leur avenir professionnel
et du choix de leur spécialité donc ce
test a eu lieu il a bien eu lieu comme
tous les tests et ça aussi c'est de la
prévention nous avons constaté des
difficultés elles sont corrigées il y
aura un nouveau test avant de pouvoir
mettre cette plateforme totalement
opérationnelle en juin je vous remercie
oui merci Monsieur le Ministre nos
étudiants en médecine ont connu beaucoup
de déconvenue donc cette période avec
des confinements à répétition des
enseignements à distance et du stress il
méritent davantage de considération la
France a un besoin urgent nouveau
médecin tout le monde le sait ici
particulièrement au Sénat nous devons
tout mettre en oeuvre pour réussir pour
que les chances de réussite soit de leur
côté merci
la parole est à notre collègue Jacques
le nez pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
ce que les élus ne supportent plus c'est
de servir de défouloir ces mots sont
ceux du président l'Association des
Maires du Morbihan prononçait lors de la
présentation des chiffres des démissions
intervenues depuis 3 ans la situation
est inédite dans le département
4 élus municipaux d'émissionne chaque
semaine depuis 2020 le mandat local
n'attire plus le Morbihan n'est pas une
exception en Loire-Atlantique un élu
local d'émission de chaque jour et nous
savons que le phénomène est national
plusieurs constats concours à ces
désengagements les élus subissent des
violences de tout nature physique
verbale via les réseaux sociaux et trop
souvent les plaintes sont classées sans
suite les élus sont résignées et
exaspérés l'empilement des normes la
lourdeur administrative décourage et
bonne volonté même les plus motivés ont
du mal à concilier vie professionnelle
et mandat un mandat chronophage est mal
indemnisé enfin le maire voit réduire
ses compétences propres alors que
l'urbanisme constitue un ultime élément
d'attractivité de la fonction
l'objectif zan complexifie leur mission
c'est un dernier coup de massue sur un
engagement déjà mal en point au-delà de
cette vague de démission la question se
pose sur la capacité même à maintenir un
fonctionnement régulier des
collectivités et à pourvoir aux
fonctions d'élus madame la Première
ministre comment comptez-vous redonner
des moyens et du sens au mandat de maire
et plus généralement à celui d'élus
local ils sont les premiers remparts et
les garants des fondements de notre
démocratie
pour vous répondre la parole
et à Olivier vérante-parole du
gouvernement vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Jacques Launay
vous avez raison de le souligner d'abord
la France a besoin de l'engagement de
ces élus locaux on en a un besoin
absolument vital il y a pas de vie
communale pas de vie départementale
régionale sans l'action déterminée des
liloko et on sait je suis convaincu que
les Français le savent aussi ce qui
fonde l'engagement des élus locaux c'est
pas certainement pas la pas du gain ou
la gloriole que ça pourrait apporter
c'est un engagement service des autres
on est d'accord je fais j'ouvre là je
fais là un euphémisme et c'est dur
d'être élu local
qui se réveille à 5h du matin quand la
neige est tombée un peu trop fort cette
nuit et que les routes sont encombrées
c'est le maire
qui doit intervenir lorsque des conflits
de vaginage peuvent dégénérer c'est le
maire qui est pris entre les injonctions
paradoxales et contradictoires parfois
vous l'avez dit vous-même avec des
normes qui s'imposent depuis Paris et la
difficulté des applications le
territoire c'est les mères alors la
moindre des choses qu'on puisse faire
c'est offrir la protection que les élus
locaux méritent dans une France qui
constate jour après jour la montée de la
violence sur les réseaux sociaux parfois
la violence verbale parfois jusque dans
les hémicycles
et parfois de la violence physique
également il était indispensable d'agir
alors des choses ont été faites en 2019
nous avons renforcé le régime de
protection des élus qui s'apparente
désormais à la protection fonctionnelle
applicable aux agents publics notamment
lorsque un élu fait l'objet de poursuite
pour des fautes qui sont détachables de
ces fonctions ou alors lorsqu'il est
victime de violence ou d'outrage à
l'occasion ou du fait de ses fonctions
sous protection qui peut également être
accordée à leur demande au conjoint
enfant ascendant direct des élus qui
seraient décédés dans l'exercice ou de
fêtes de leur fonction à raison des
faits à l'origine de ce décès c'est pas
un fonctionnement très lourd c'est pas
un financement très lourd et donc la loi
le corps nu ensuite créé l'obligation de
souscrire à une garantie qui permet de
couvrir au-delà de ça le conseil
juridique l'assistance psychologique les
coûts qui résultent de l'obligation pour
les communes de protection fonctionnelle
des membres de conseil municipal c'est
un dispositif qui rend ainsi plus
effective moins risqué la mise en oeuvre
de la protection fonctionnelle par les
communes il a eu lapl Delattre aussi et
puis ma collègue Dominique force elle
avait été là vous aurez raconté comment
nous allons créer une cellule d'analyse
et de lutte contre les atteintes aux
élus locaux au sein du ministère de
l'Intérieur croyant notre détermination
pour avancer en l'occurrence et en la
matière et on avancera avec vous
monsieur le nez et merci monsieur le
ministre si n'ai rien fait cette
situation contribuera à la crise
profonde que connaissent nos
institutions car ne l'oublions pas le
maire et le représentant de l'État sur
sa commune
la parole est à notre collègue Philippe
mzec pour le groupe les républicains
vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues mesdames et messieurs les
ministres la terre d'Arménie brûle et
nous regardons ailleurs
depuis l'automne 2020 l'Arménie est en
état de siège depuis l'invasion de
l'enclave arménienne Larzac par l'armée
d'Azerbaïdjan soutenu par la Turquie qui
s'en sert comme avant-garde pour
poursuivre et achever l'éradication du
peuple arménien entamé en 1915 entre les
épisodes de guerre civile qui a déjà
fait 5000 morts et 15000 blessés en
trois ans c'est un véritable blocus
orchestré par l'Azerbaïdjan pour
empêcher les vivre et les médicaments
d'arriver jusque dans l'enclave
arménienne les seuls qui est le droit de
passage sont les Arméniens qui fuient la
guerre la famille et la misère mais il
n'ont droit qu'à un aller simple
l'Azerbaïdjan comptant sur le départ des
120 000 Arméniens restants pour poser
définitivement son joug sur ce
territoire
et ce n'est qu'une première étape pour
rayer de la carte cette terre chrétienne
quelle Arménie la plus ancienne du monde
aujourd'hui encerclé par l'expansion
musulmane depuis nos villes des
Hauts-de-Seine qui accueillent une forte
communauté d'origine arménienne nous
envoyons des vives des médicaments et
aussi des médecins en partenariat avec
lumière française
ainsi nous essayons de forcer le blocus
mais qu'attend le gouvernement au-delà
des messages d'amitié pour demander le
respect des règles internationales et du
droit des peuples l'Arménie ce petit
pays porte les mêmes valeurs que les
nôtres alors c'est vrai que l'Arménie ce
n'est pas l'Ukraine on y trouve ni
pétrole ni gaz contrairement à
l'Azerbaïdjan l'Arménie n'a rien hormis
sa foi et son courage ma question est la
ministre et donc de savoir si la France
est prêtre a mobiliser les mêmes moyens
diplomatiques voire militaire qu'on l'a
fait pour l'Ukraine pour défendre en
Arménie un peuple amis qui est en train
de mourir
merci
[Musique]
pour vous répondre la parole est comme
Madame la Ministre de l'Europe et les
affaires étrangères madame Colonna
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Balzac merci de votre question
car elle permet de rappeler que depuis
le premier jour c'est-à-dire depuis le
12 décembre la France dénonce le blocage
du corridor de latine par l'Azerbaïdjan
et ses conséquences tentent économiques
cumanitaires en effet la population
depuis cette date ne peut plus circuler
librement les vivre arrivent
de façon par simoneuse et grâce au
Comité international de la Croix-Rouge
que la France aide monsieur le sénateur
ainsi que ses partenaires de l'Union
européenne alors oui cette situation ne
peut plus durer la libre circulation
doit être rétablie sans tarder et
l'approvisionnement des populations du
haut-karaba doit être mieux assurée
d'abord parce que c'est le droit et je
les dis ici je veux le rappeler la Cour
internationale de G6 c'est prononcé par
référé il y a quelques semaines et
ensuite parce que ce blocage alimente
les tensions éloignent les perspectives
de règlement politique qui est le seul
possible donc un accord de paix que nous
recherchons et que l'Arménie recherche
monsieur sénateur avec son voisin je
prévois de me rendre à Baco et à irvan
Coran avril pour porter ce message pour
rappeler la nécessité d'une solution
politique pour rappeler la nécessité
d'abord du ccfeu auquel les deux parties
se sont engagés et pour souligner que
les menaces d'emploi de la force sont
inacceptables je le redis monsieur
sénateur nous sommes déterminés je suis
déterminé et la française elle ne
regarde pas ailleurs elle agit elle ne
parle pas je vous remercie merci
la parole est à notre
collègues Angèle Préville pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains
vous avez la parole merci
vous avez proposé par amendement à
l'Assemblée nationale la fusion de
l'IRSN et de la SN ou peut-être plutôt
l'absorption de l'IRSN par la SN cette
loi qui propose tout un panel de
mécanismes dit d'accélération avait déjà
été examinée au Sénat sans cet
amendement quel drôle d'idée quand on a
un parc vieillissant nécessitant toute
notre attention et un programme très
ambitieux de 8 voire 14 voire plus
encore de nouveaux réacteurs fort
heureusement les députés plus
raisonnables l'ont rejeté dois-je
rappeler quand la matière nous ne sommes
à l'abri de rien dans le pays le plus
nucléarisé au monde nous pouvons
remercier tous les jours notre sûreté
car nous n'avons pas eu jusque là
d'accidents nucléaires l'IRSN est
indépendant exerce des fonctions
d'expertise et de recherche qu'il
fournit à la SN et c'est la SN en tant
qu'autorité qui prend les décisions
c'est basiques c'est efficace et c'est
une nécessité absolue pourquoi casser ce
qui fonctionne pourquoi provoquer de la
confusion voir du désordre les salariés
de l'URSS sont d'ailleurs sous le choc
KO debout sur quelle étude d'impact
d'ailleurs repose ce choix l'arrêt de 4
réacteurs à l'automne suite à la
détection de corrosion sous contrainte
pour lequel on a agité le spectre du
placard a-t-il agacé a-t-il provoqué
lire qui se résumerait à la sûreté ça
suffit comme ça nous sommes au printemps
il n'y a pas eu de blackout mais de
nouvelles corrosion ont été découvertes
la réalité c'est que plus que jamais
nous avons besoin d'organismes robustes
ayant largement fait leurs preuves et
même reconnu internationalement notre
boussole en matière du nucléaire doit
être cette aigu conscience des périls
dont parle et garmorin votre volonté
votre volonté d'effacement de l'URSS a
été sèchement rejetée par l'Assemblée
nationale elle est non seulement
malvenue mais surtout dangereuse on se
doute que vous n'allez pas lâcher prise
puisque c'est l'ADN de ce gouvernement
madame la ministre sur ce sujet comme
sur les autres gouverner s’était
la parole de calaministes de la
transition énergétique qu'on a punir une
HP
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Préville en matière
énergétique le président de la
République a un objectif ambitieux faire
de la France le premier grand pays a
sorti des énergies fossiles et à
reprendre en main notre destin
énergétique c'est dans ce contexte que
le gouvernement travaille à un programme
nucléaire de 6 nouveaux EPR 2 et à la
mise à l'étude de 8 supplémentaires
c'est un projet pour notre indépendance
énergétique c'est un projet pour la
planète c'est un projet qui doit aussi
nous permettre de reprendre le fil de la
plus grande aventure industrielle
française depuis les années 70 le
Conseil de politique nucléaire du 3
février dernier qui s'est tenu sous
l'égide du président de la République et
de la première ministre a mis à jour la
feuille de route pour mobiliser tous les
maillons de notre filière nucléaire
c'est dans ce contexte que le
gouvernement a décidé le renforcement le
renforcement de notre sûreté nucléaire
en avançant sur le ranchement de la SN
et de l'URSS de quoi s'agit-il très
simplement il est proposé d'élargir les
missions de l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire sur des modèles éprouvés des
autorités de sûreté du Canada ou encore
des États-Unis en rapprochant la
décision le contrôle des missions
d'expertise et de recherche il s'agit
donc au fond de réunir sous la même
manière qu'il y a le statut le plus
indépendant celui d'autorité
administrative indépendante le statut de
la SN plus indépendant que les RSN deux
services qui concourent au même service
public à la même mission de service
public au terme de cette réforme
l'Autorité de sûreté nucléaire ou cette
composition a estagnée RSN deviendrait
la deuxième autorité de sûreté du monde
en termes de moyens humains et
financiers avec une crédibilité
scientifique renforcée nous sommes donc
bien loin des fantasmes et des modèles
que vous évoquez suite au vote hier du
projet de loi nucléaire à une très large
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale qui
demande entre autres au gouvernement un
rapport explicitant les modalités de
mise en oeuvre de cette réforme et la
vie de lopex j'avancerai je demanderai
au sénateur avec mon collègue Franck
Riester les modalités selon lesquelles
le Sénat veut être associé à cette
réforme et effectivement dans la
concertation pourquoi vaincro pour la
clé
la parole est à notre collègue Damien
Rognard
pour les républicains
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre Colona mais chers collègues
après la visite du président Macron en
août 2022 en Algérie suivi de la visite
de la première ministre accompagnée de
16 de féministes après la visite de
Monsieur Darmanin en décembre 2022 qui
nous explique à son retour que tout va
bien et qui supprime les mesures de
limitation à 50% de délivrance de visa
pour la France il semble que nous ayons
tout lâché mais pour quel résultat
les délivrances de laisser passer
consulaire de l'Algérie pour les auqtf
étaient déjà extrêmement faibles moins
de 1% et avec le rappel de son
ambassadeur en France le 8 février 2023
l'Algérie via ses 18 consulats sur notre
territoire annonce inédits ne plus
délivrer un seul laisser passer
consulaire et menace de suspendre la
délivrance des visas pour les Français
souhaitant se rendre en Algérie je
t'aime moi non plus ou en sommes-nous
madame la ministre où en sommes-nous de
la main tendue et de cette repentance
incessante envers l'Algérie où sont les
résultats la réforme de votre ministère
qui écarte des diplomates chevronnés de
véritables négociateurs et bâtisseurs de
pont entre nos pays respectifs
commencent à faire vaciller toute un
édifice à quand des mesures fortes pour
une France forte et respectée des
mesures de restortion existent et sont
pourtant simples suspendent la
délivrance des visas aux Algériens
souhaitant se rendre en France
parallélisme des formes et égalité
traitement ni plus ni moins pour
répondre la parole le ministre de
l'Europe des Affaires étrangères madame
la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur
sénateur avec l'Algérie nous avons
initié une dynamique ambitieuse depuis
la visite d'amitié du président de la
République les 25 26 et 27 août 2022
suivi de la réunion du cinquième
Comité intergouvernemental de haut
niveau sous l'autorité de madame la
Première ministre et de son homologue
les 9 et 10 octobre 2022 et vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur sénateur le ministre de
l'Intérieur s'est ensuite rendu en
Algérie le 17 décembre dernier et je
note aussi vous l'avez oublié la visite
en France du chef d'état-major de
l'armée algérienne une première depuis
bien longtemps
alors Monsieur sénateur il faut éviter
de tomber dans le piège de ceux qui
souhaitent faire échouer notre ambition
ce n'est pas votre vœu j'en suis sûr
alors nous allons continuer à travailler
avec les autorités algériennes à la
levée des difficultés constatées car la
profondissement de notre relation est
dans l'intérêt de nos deux pays et c'est
dans cet esprit que la France traite
notamment de la question de la migration
entre l'Algérie et la France cela
concerne les visas avec un groupe de
travail conjoint qui doit favoriser les
mobilités notamment entre les jeunes et
en particulier les jeunes professionnels
mais cette coopération oui pour être
cohérente doit également permettre
d'assurer le retour en Algérie des
Algériens en situation irrégulière comme
le droit le commande et ça fait partie
de nos priorités immédiates nous y
travaillons nous y travaillons notamment
avec le président teboun dont je suis
sûr monsieur sénateur que vous aurez
noté avec intérêt les dernières
déclarations
il sera toujours temps de remettre le
sujet sur la table avec fermeté enfin je
crois au Portal rappeler que la naïveté
peut-être considérée comme de la
faiblesse non madame la ministre nous ne
voulons pas d'une France qui se couche
mais d'une France qui se fait respecter
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue
Pierre-Antoine Lévy pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
ma question s'adressée aux ministres de
l'économie je vois qu'il est parti
monsieur le ministre en mars 2022 le
prix du baril de pétrole Brent aussi
entre 115 et 130 dollars les prix à la
pompe étaient élevés avec un litre de
gazole il y a 2,11 et un litre 200
plombs à 2,6 en moyenne 12 mois plus
tard alors que le baril de pétrole n'a
jamais été aussi bas depuis 15 mois à 75
dollars et un euro qui remonte les prix
des carburants ne baissent pourtant
quasiment pas ou très peu à la pompe ces
jours-ci les prix restent toujours très
élevés pour les automobilistes avec un
lit de gasoil à 1,82 et un livre de
Simplon à 1,97 en moyenne nul besoin
d'être prix Nobel d'économie pour se
rendre compte que lorsque le prix du
baril augmente les prix augmentent très
fortement mais lorsque le prix du baril
baisse significativement les prix la
bombe ne baisse que très peu monsieur le
ministre je sais que l'on aime bien
faire des comparaisons avec les voisins
européens aussi je me suis permis de
regarder ce qui se fait dans quelques
pays Allemagne un euro 76 pour le Simple
Plan 95 un euro 73 pour le Gaso Belgique
1,65 pour le sans-plomb 95,70 pour le
gasoil Espagne 1,62 pour le Simple Plan
95 et 1,55 pour le gazole comparaison
les parisons mais comprenez que dans le
contexte actuel de tension économique
sociale et maintenant politique de
concitoyens ont la réalité de ne pas
payer le juste prix et il est évident
que ce n'est pas nouveau chèque
carburant qu'il veut réclame ce qu'ils
veulent c'est une vraie baisse des prix
à la pompe monsieur le ministre j'ai
conscience que les prix des carburants
est un mécanisme complexe mais il est
temps que les prix soient transparents
et enfin cohérents avec les variations
du prix du baril alors ma question est
la suivante monsieur le ministre que
compte faire le gouvernement a très
court terme pour que les prix à la pompe
reflètent en fin de manière plus visible
les cours du marché de pétrole je vous
remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre il est chargé de l'Industrie
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Lévy d'abord je vous prie
d'excuser le ministre Bruno Le Maire qui
a dû qui a dû s'absenter et qui m'a
chargé du coup de vous répondre en son
lieu et place vous dire ensuite vous
l'avez dit que les mécanismes de
transmission du prix du baril sur les
marchés et du prêt à la pompe sont des
mécanismes complexes qui prennent
souvent un peu de temps et qui reflète
de manière incomplète la volatilité
extrême qu'on observe sur les marchés
vous l'avez dit le baril du Brent le
prix du baril a baissé de manière très
forte la semaine dernière reflétant
essentiellement les incertitudes
financières il fait yoyo au jour le jour
c'est vrai que les prix à la pompe ne
font pas yoyo un jour le jour et reflète
plutôt avec retard les évolutions à la
hausse à la baisse des prix à la pompe
vous l'avez dit le taux de change entre
les rôles de l'art peut aussi avoir un
impact positif ou négatif sur le prix à
la pompe je dois reconnaître que ces
derniers jours les désorganisations dans
les chaînes d'approvisionnement
conduire les distributeurs à
reconstituer des stocks de précaution
tout ceci étant évidemment le reflet
d'un certain nombre de conflits et de
blocages qui ne sont sans doute pas très
opportun pour la simplicité de la
livraison de l'essence bref tout ça est
un peu compliqué cela dit cela dit le
prix à l'essence a baissé quand même ces
derniers jours par rapport au chiffre
que vous mentionnés on est plutôt aux
alentours de 1,90 pour le super semblant
et 1 80 pour le gasoil ça commence à
baisser j'espère bien que si le prix du
baril continue à baisser le prix de
l'essence ce sera aussi ensuite votre
est enfin votre question me permet de
rappeler aux françaises et aux Français
que le gouvernement et le Parlement
d'ailleurs ont adopté un chèque de 100
euros qui permet à 4 millions de
Françaises et aux Français d'ores et
déjà de bénéficier d'une facture à la
pompe réduite j'engage celles et ceux
qui n'ont pas encore réclamé ce chèque
de se connecter sur un pot.gouv.fr ça
prend 5 minutes c'est extrêmement simple
et ça rapporte gros puisque ça rapporte
100 euros merci
Monsieur Lévy
oui monsieur le ministre merci pour
votre réponse mais comme vous l'avez dit
quand le prix du baril monte le
lendemain le prix de l'essence augmente
fortement ou le surlendemain par contre
quand les prix baissent il faut attendre
plusieurs semaines avant de voir une
matérialisation à la du prix à la pompe
ce n'est pas normal j'espère que le
gouvernement pourra inciter à plus de
transparence merci merci
merci madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres nous
avons terminé avec les questions
gouvernement notre prochaine réunion
portant question d'actualité au
gouvernement aura lieu le mercredi 29
mars à 15h la séance va être suspendue
sur la reprise assez dans 30 pour le
débat à la suite du dépôt du rapport
public annuel de la Cour des comptes la
séance est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement que vous
avez pu suivre en direct et en
intégralité sur l'antenne de Public
Sénat parmi les moments forts on
retiendra dans cette séance cet échange
vif au tout début un des questions
gouvernement entre Guillaume Gontard et
la chef du gouvernement le point de
départ c'est ce moment dans l'interview
d'Emmanuel Macron au trésor de TF1 et de
France 2 où il a comparé les
manifestations en France avec ce qui
s'était passé au Capitole aux États-Unis
ou encore au Brésil il faut dire on
respecte on écoute a-t-il dit mais on ne
peut pas accepter ni les factieux ni les
factions Guillaume Gontard le chef de
fil des écologistes a dénoncé alors un
président hors sol je cite écoutez c'est
donc en début de séance
le prince Président nous a gratifié à
leur méridienne de sa bonne parole
totalement hors sol il a annoncé
continué à avancer à marche forcée
totalement hors sol il a osé comparer
l'un des plus grands mouvements
populaires de notre histoire à la
sédition factieuse des suprématistes
blancs envahissant le Capitole
totalement hors sol il
a un restant sans avoir
un de la police qui sous vos ordres
tabasse nasse jette des grenades en
pleine tête roulent à moto sur les gens
intimides et arrête
car à l'armée du Défenseur des droits
voilà et à chaque fois que c'est un
président de groupe qui pose une
question c'est la chef du gouvernement
qui lui répond donc ils avaient devant
qui a pris la parole sa première prise
de parole publique depuis l'interview
d'Emmanuel Macron au trésor de TF1 et de
France 2 et on voit maintenant la
stratégie de l'exécutif c'est de tenter
de réexpliquer le bien-fondé de la
réforme des retraites écouter Elisabeth
après des
semurs il est temps de rappeler quelques
vérités oui cette réforme est nécessaire
pour assurer l'avenir de nos retraites
sans elle les déficits ce serait
accumulés et nous aurions été contraints
à des hausses d'impôts ou des baisses de
pension au détriment des plus modestes
et des classes moyennes voilà la
première ministre qui a tenté de
rétablir quelques vérités